-Welcome back to the show.
-Oh, my goodness.
-I love having you on.
I want to talk about everything.
I don't even know
really where to start
because we have
this new book here
that is kind of not
for children, really.
-No, it's -- it's my --
Well, it's not my book, even.
-No, it's not.
-It's the pigeon's book.
I'm just a translator.
-Ah!
So the pigeon is what --
is just fed up. Finally.
-Pigeon just discovered
that he works in books.
[ Laughter ]
-And said, "Are you kidding me?"
-And he's not happy
about the ending.
-Yeah.
-Right?
He never gets
what he wants in the books.
-No.
-And you are laughing at him.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes. And he does not --
-He's not happy about that,
either.
-He wants to be respected.
-Right.
And like all New York City
pigeons, he's a philosopher.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, he is.
So, this is his lost
and profound wisdom.
-Yeah.
-The peckings of a birdbrain.
-This one I love. It says,
"Success is 99% perspiration
and 5% approximation."
[ Laughter ]
Did you know that the pigeon
was gonna take off
when you first did this?
-No, I didn't.
Basically, 'cause everybody
told me it wouldn't.
So I create -- I do a little
sketchbook every year
for my clients and friends.
I've done it for 30 years.
And one year, I did one.
It was called "Don't Let
the Pigeon Drive the Bus."
And I thought it was a funny,
weird little thing.
And my wife at the time --
who's still my wife.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. Wow.
-Happily.
-Okay. I was like,
"Who did I just --
Who did I say hello to?"
Like, wow.
That could've been rough.
[ Laughs ]
Yeah, yeah.
-Yet at the time...
-Yeah, yeah.
-...was working as
a lower-school librarian,
and she brought the sketchbook.
I actually brought a copy.
This is the original.
It's a little sketchbook I did
for clients and friends,
and she brought this
and read it to the kids
and said, "I think
this is a children's book."
And I said, "Oh, you don't know
what you're talking about."
-Yeah.
-"No, that's obviously it's not.
It's just a little sketchbook.
It's a little thing
for friends and whatever."
Yeah, that's it.
-And this turned into...
-Well, so what I did was,
I went to every publisher
in New York, and they said,
"We agree with you.
It isn't a book.
Your wife is wrong."
[ Laughter ]
-Really, this is not --
-They said one word.
It's unusual.
And I finally found a publisher
that said,
"Unusual is not pejorative."
-Wow.
-And then they published it.
-Wow!
-So there you go.
And that was 20 years ago.
20 years ago.
-I mean, is that wild?
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's amazing.
To look at what you've done.
Because now you --
-And that's for you.
That's my gift for you.
Yeah.
-An original?
-Yeah, that's it. Yeah.
-Are you kidding me?
-Absolutely.
No, I'm not kidding you.
I'm absolutely not kidding you.
[ Laughter ]
-I -- I -- I -- I, you know,
I'm the biggest fan of yours.
This means a lot to me.
You are a hero in our house,
by the way.
We read every one
of "Elephant and Piggie" books.
We have everything,
and we read them.
I love your books.
I want to read them
without the kids.
-Great. Well, if you read them,
what you really should do,
if you love your kids,
every time,
it should be a fresh copy.
[ Laughter ]
-See? It's genius.
Genius, as well, yeah.
-Well, I love that intimacy.
I mean, like, I love the idea
of parents and kids
doing this together, you know?
So part of what I want
to do in my books is,
I want my books
not to just be books.
I want them to be sparks.
I want my books to be played.
So that's why every character
is easy to draw.
But I also want
for the grown-ups,
I want to give them
a shame-ectomy.
-A shame-ectomy.
-Yeah.
Because here's your chance
to be ridiculous.
Here's your chance to yell
"No! Let me drive the bus!"
-Yeah. Yes!
-And being -- and being ashamed
is a learned disease, right?
-Yeah.
-Millions of teenagers are dying
of shame every day, right?
-Yeah, I'm one of them. Yeah.
-Embarrassment.
Embarrassed.
-Of course.
-So what I'm hoping to do
is bring that moment together.
It's not just about the kids,
but it's about the kids
seeing the parents
or the grown-ups in their lives
being silly, which allows them
to be more silly,
which allows the kids
to feel that
their silliness has validity.
-Yeah, and you can be silly.
It's fine to be silly.
-Absolutely.
-It's fun to be silly.
-Does it blow your brains
to think that you're teaching
so many kids how to read?
Like, when parents
come up to you and go,
"You taught my kid how to read."
I mean, that's --
My kids learned on your books.
-That's very, very sweet.
But I think that I really only
put 49% of the book on the page.
It is the grown-ups and the kids
and the way they strive
and they create that makes
these things special.
And I want to make sure that
I create enough space for them
to make the stories
part of themselves, right?
-Wow. Yes, they are --
I totally agree.
And you do it every time.
-Thank you, thank you.
-It is so --
-Thank you.
-It's so clever.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Your books are simple in the
best way, but so clever, also.
-Well, simple and easy
are opposites.
-Yeah.
-Right?
So, writing a picture book
is as easy
as describing the history
of Byzantium in three words.
-Yeah, you --
Yeah. Probably can't do it.
Yeah. Yeah.
But it's brilliantly done.
And I was asking you
about this last time.
We were talking about
how you draw the pigeon.
And you have an idea
There's something fun
you wanted us to try tonight.
-Yeah. So, look, I love drawing,
and this is why I love drawing.
For everyone,
not just for artists.
But, like,
when the band is playing,
music is physicalized emotion.
Their body is creating emotion,
and it comes out as music.
Well, drawing
is physicalized empathy.
When you are drawing something,
you are thinking
about that thing,
and you are understanding
that thing deeper.
So I make sure that
every one of my characters
is easy enough
for a 5-year-old to draw.
I think you have the drawing
ability of a 5-year-old.
-Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
-I think the band has the
drawing ability of a 5-year-old.
-Yeah, there you go.
-Of several 5-year-olds.
And I think you,
the audience, as well, right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Everyone,
look under your seats.
Everyone has a clipboard
and a marker.
Mo, you've drawn the pigeon
thousands of times.
-Yes.
-Can you teach 200 people here
how to draw a pigeon?
-I'm gonna try and teach
200 people how to draw a pigeon.
All right, here we go.
-[ Laughs ]
-You're about to draw a cartoon!
All you have to know
to draw a cartoon
is how to write your name.
Because your name
is a bunch of letters
put together
in the right order.
And a cartoon is
a bunch of shapes
put together in the right order.
I'm gonna make it easier.
We're gonna draw
the pigeon's head.
You only have to know
how to write my name,
Mo, and you will draw
the pigeon's head.
So we're gonna do
a call-and-repeat, right?
Call and response. Ready?
-Yep.
-You guys got your pens?
-I see 'em.
Got your paper?
All right.
From the O, here we go.
Repeat after me.
Big O.
-Big O!
-Middle O.
-Middle O!
-Little O!
-Darken it in!
-M hat.
-Got it?
Put it's sideways.
-There you go!
-That's pigeon right there!
Come on!
Audience, let me see it!
-Hold 'em up!
-Let me see your pigeon!
-Look at that!
Look at that!
[ Dinging ]
-That's fantastic.
Look at that.
Isn't that amazing?
Mo Willems, everybody!
That's how you do it.
-You guys are great!
-Both of his books
are available now.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show"!
Stick around.